all right michelle yes michelle
where'd you grow up where are you from
originally hollywood california
hollywood
and uh tell me about your childhood you
had both your parents when you were
young
no my father left us when i was six
months old
my mom was a single parent um until
i was about nine she remarried or she
met somebody
and and hooked up with them and stayed
with them for 20 years and how was
how would you describe your childhood
horrible
why would you say it's horrible my mom
didn't like me
that would make it she drew me out when
i was 13. her exact words were i don't
want any [ __ ] living with me
oh so you're you're trans yes oh wow i
didn't know
and uh so your mom didn't
accept your orientation no
or my lifestyle choices yeah so at 13
you left
to be on my own i guess i went to go
stay with my grandmother
she was mentally ill and um it was hard
to live with her because she didn't want
to pay the rent
so we were always constantly going
through an eviction um
to try to help support the house i
started to
prostitute myself in hollywood
and um santa monica over south america
yeah and i was there doing that for
two years and i started did phone sex
um then i did like webcam shows and
then uh different kinds of sex related
things
how does how's doing all that different
sex work how did it affect you
emotionally
uh it killed my sexual appetite it made
me distrust men
um made me my whole channel i think
makes people distressed man
all these stories it made me um value my
own self-worth
you know reevaluate my dignity
even if i still even had any right
it's got to be so hard emotionally just
to interact with men
in these ways right i was a 14 when i
got sexually assaulted
by two men and
since then it was really difficult for
me to be able to be comfortable around
men of color
um it's happened several times since
then
as recently as just like a month ago
you've been on skid row for a while um
on
for about two years where do you stay
you're in a tent or something i'm going
to make sure
make shift to canopy
um my last county got burned down
i've been in three fifteen fires since
i've become
homeless um i suspect from
hate crimes most people don't like me
because
of the way i look or because of what i
am
so you become a target for hate crime
yeah
and are drugs a part of your life oh
yeah
i guess yes the first time i tried meth
i was 14
i was at a nightclub and somebody
introduced it like here sniff this i was
like
hey i sniffed it and went dancing for
three days straight
how many days what's your record for how
many days you've been up i was up for
three weeks non-stop three weeks notice
i was in high school
that was the longest i've ever been up i
can't be i can't be up more than three
days now
i start i start uh speaking in tongues
i can't understand what i'm saying
everything's jumbled up so yeah i've
seen a lot of that behavior
so how are you supporting yourself now
still same thing
i'm on public existence and um i applied
for
social security disability i'm still
waiting to respond a response for that
the last time i got they said i was too
young and i didn't have enough points
acquired to get disability
so i appealed that i'm waiting to get a
response from that
how do you know i'm 41 you're 41.
do you still do sex work sometimes
unfortunately yeah
very well very very suddenly um you
don't make much money out here on the
streets anymore
it's not like used to be 20 years ago
um being being homeless is kind of
difficult to have
clients because you don't have a place
to see them i feel really uncomfortable
seeing people on the streets
um i don't feel safe i don't
i don't know where they're taking me i
don't feel comfortable in a car i think
we might get stopped by the cops who
might get arrested
um or we might i just might get just get
gay bashed or trans bash because
someone's what's the worst thing that's
happened to you
gang rape um
[Music]
been sexually assaulted physically
assaulted
my tent being burned down with me in it
i was asleep
my mom throwing me out of my house with
her
i really did love her a lot
do you get depressed sometimes or i
think i'm depressed constantly
i didn't realize it until just recently
how much of my life was
surrounded by uh depression
um i've always looked at everything on
the positive side i was trying to be
very a positive person but
being without a home it's it's like
everything's just down
sitting around dirt and living in filth
and
having rats run around you constantly
i'm not talking about people rats i'm
talking about rat rats
they're uh it's they eat up your food
they have diseases it's really dirty
it's scary
not having a place to shower
yeah there's so many factors that would
make
anyone depressed down here
lack of lack of privacy that too
do you do you feel like you were
uh trans before you were molested as a
child
oh yeah yeah yeah i felt like i was a
girl since i was about three
i remember i told my mom something about
it and she's like oh no you're out of
your mind you're crazy
she hit me with a flip-flop going over
your sandals and that was the first time
i felt shame for being
what i was or what i felt and um
that was remarkably painful
i learned from then i had to hide it and
it wasn't until i was like 14 13 14 13
about 13 40. i couldn't hide anymore
i had to just i had to act upon it
because i feel like if i didn't i was
just gonna
i was gonna die with it in my heart and
i would never feel fulfilled so many of
the trans people that i've
spoken to have said that their happiest
moment was when they finally just
came out and didn't fight it anymore it
was one of my one of my happiest moments
leaving my mom's house because i got to
finally be who i wanted to be
i got a chance to dress up at my
grandmother's house and and
feel comfortable i went to a gay lesbian
high school called eagles
um here in los angeles and at that
school was able to freely be who i
wanted to be
they didn't care it was um ellie's first
game lesbian high school
and there was they were quoted and so
dear friends today yes
i do some of them still from high school
oh wow
that's great
and how do you what does your typical
day look like
i wake up um i eat
i go out and search for water bring home
five gallons of water
um do whatever washing i need to do
have make lunch or have lunch for dinner
get high and then stay up because
nighttime is very scary
i didn't actually um start enough again
i did that throughout high school
i stopped when i started my transition
um i didn't
just from like 18 to like 30 i didn't
touch it
um i during that time had met somebody
and was married for nine and a half
years
um completely sober cold turkey which
was kind of cool
but then um at the end of our
relationship released he was a
alcoholic slash drug addict and that
kind of got me into the
motor bowl of he can do that i can do
what i want to do so i started
smoking pot again and started doing
other things and then
when i became homeless the fear of
being intent alone at night made me
start getting high on meth
so i could stay up at night and not be
cold and not feel the cold and
not feel so much fear of being alone i'm
innocent
because most most of the bad things
happen that night yeah yeah during the
day it's fairly safe here
pretty safe actually it's just a lot
safer than i imagined yeah sometimes
it's hard to imagine that things that go
on at night yeah
could happen here but it's a very
different neighborhood definitely
definitely very
very different what are your
what's your dream scenario that could
happen at this point in your life
are you hoping to fall in love and meet
some of them
well that already happened i met
somebody i fell in love and i was
married for nine and a half years
from that experience i learned that
nothing lasts forever so i guess in my
next relationship if
i'm lucky enough to have one is to just
enjoy it join them
while i have the chance to enjoy them um
i thank god every day that i i'm able to
wake up and enjoy life
from here on out and i thank him for
giving me the chance the opportunity of
having love for nine and a half years
some people don't ever have that in
their life so
i'm pretty lucky if i get another chance
to fall in love that'd be awesome but
i feel fulfilled do you consider
yourself a happy person
sometimes you mentioned depression
before so
sometimes people are both depressed and
happy at the same time
yeah i look happy on the outside that's
what's most important
everyone thinks i'm happy so even though
inside i'm
withered away and crying no one needs to
know about that
that's the way my mom taught me take it
till you make it
what's your biggest regret
hmm not finishing school
did you have dreams of doing something
with i want to be an architect
i want to be a professional i want to do
work in an office in a high-rise
building and just
be somebody important did you take
hormones or anything like that
oh yeah i took hormones i took them home
for about a year but um i gained like a
hundred pounds
in one year i used to be like 130 and
then i went i blew up
to 250 and then um i'm a heaviest
i was 250 and my husband left me at that
time but i was oh
i took almost a year and i gained all
that weight and i was never able to get
it off and it was until i became
homeless i started to lose weight
because it's hard to it's hard to if you
feed yourself out here
you know how you don't have a consistent
diet so i lost like about
almost like 80 pounds typically on
crystal meth people will lose weight
that's also another true possibility
yeah
that was my secret
you've been in love before yes three
times
my first relationship when i was
fourteen um
this is an older guy um it didn't last
very long i was about
six months and then my second
relationship was when i was
eight 17 18 someone who was 22
and that lasted about two years and then
my last relationship where i was 23.
he was 21 so i was older than him and
that lasted nine and a half years
and i've been single for the last uh
five years no longer and i'm 41 now so
something like
that um i uh
found out he was uh our relationship
ended when i uh my mom passed away and i
found out
uh i found my dad's phone number for the
first time ever
and i met my dad after so many years
um i was 33 years 34 when i met him for
the first time
um my my husband sent me to florida go
meet him
and give me some money to spend with him
when i came back my boyfriend was
moved in with his dealer and um i had
taken all the good stuff basically moved
out of our apartment and moved all the
good stuff out
checked a good car took the good you
know tv and
dashed with his dealer and lived happily
ever after with her
and um from there it was just like a
downward spiral
because it he was definitely my support
system he was with my rock
of sanity um
without when when that happened i didn't
have my mom
my mom passed away so i didn't have
anybody to
really talk to um
so i kind of just did a downward spiral
a little bit little
and so i found drugs and then i lost my
apartment and
i'm homeless what do you worry about now
not being able to get out of being
homelessness um
i've applied was a couple different
agencies for housing
um because it's hard to maintain your
things on the street
um so especially a phone i've gone
through probably like
15 phone numbers in the last year um
when they had housing for me i didn't
have a phone so they couldn't contact me
i had no idea that there was something
available for me
so every time i i get a chance to change
my phone number with these agencies um
i check in and there is there isn't and
so i've been patiently been waiting
i haven't gotten response yet
do you feel like you were loved as a
child
until they found out what i really was
um my grandmother loved me
she loved me dearly she she accepted me
for for who i was on in
the inside versus who i was on the
outside um
she remember telling me i remember her
telling me that she knew that there was
something different about me when i was
like
three years old and telling my mom and
my mom said oh no
it's just your imagination and then as i
started to get older
my feminine qualities kept persistent
and um
my grandma was like i knew it i knew it
i always knew you know there's something
special about you
and um my mom just didn't want to didn't
want to leave you want to put on
blinders
of course you know i didn't there's a
lot of contributing factors why or
you know i was raised by two women i
didn't have a father figure to teach me
about masculinity
um i mean
there's a lot of variables that could be
the answer with it
it is what it is and i am what i am
that's all that i am would you say is
the most important
lesson you've learned in your life be
humble
nobody likes an arrogant person not even
when you look like this
no
all right michelle well thank you so
much for sharing your story no problem
thank you for having me yeah i wish you
the best of luck thank you thank you
hope you get housing
bye thank you
you